so you're missing your your front teeth
I only have six teeth in my mouth how
did you ID gum everything really so you
think I do there are certain foods that
I eat that I have to cut in small pieces
and pretty much I just swallow them
whole just like a snake does yeah so
it's taken some time to get used to it a
different way of eating so you know
there are different things that change
in my life because of my transformation
and eating is one of them
the hearing is another part everything
is much louder to me now oh my god yeah
like and whenever fires like sirens and
things go by I just want to cover my ear
as I'm saying yes but ya know I have had
32 teeth removed and I only have six
teeth in my mouth representing the mouth
of the rattlesnake at this present time
I have a female broad chest because I
have breasts that were developed through
hormones so they're natural breasts then
love them so much and but I also have
male genitals down here only the penis
the the ahead of my testicles removed
last year so I am a unique right now if
you see the pattern of what's going on
there's several stages of evolution so
my transformation is a metamorphosis and
I will reach the end stage as a full
dragon when I have all my procedures
completed including a penectomy which is
coming and is coming off because I'm not
going to get a vagina I'm just going to
get it connected me so I will be a
genderless dragon that's what dragons
are
what Israel
my name is Tiamat legion Medusa and you
are I am known as the dragon lady
because I am the dragon lady yeah I am I
am the world's most modified transsexual
I am a an individual going to the
process of two major transitions life
changing transitions life forming
transitions and life-giving transitions
it's not just going through a transition
it's a different life so like being
reborn I I think of myself as being a
real-life example of being born again
because I am morphing their body
modification into a human dragon it's
conceptual body art and I'm also in the
process of becoming a a woman
I'm meld to female transsexual I decided
when I just started my transition which
was it's 22 years ago that I was going
to live my life
dumi and people didn't like it and some
people are really really ugly but a lot
of people like Los Angeles has received
me with open arms and welcomed me I'm
from Houston Texas yes
when I first got here I was in the
middle of Skid Row in a in a shelter
because I was ended up homeless so for a
month and a half
oh my oh my Lucifer it was just it was
crazy and so right now I'm on the
outskirts of Skid Row and it's great
because I love for I am now I lived a
miserable childhood and early teen life
and early adult life
and one of the reasons that it was life
was miserable for me is because I was
born in the wrong body I was born in the
boys body and everyone always treated me
like a boy I had to do boy things and
and act like a boy and pretend to like
girls and and all that until I finally
said you know and I was a teenager I
think I was a freshman in high school I
said you know what I'm done with this I
don't care if I'm the only person in
town that's gay I'm gonna be openly gay
and I walked down the streets of this of
the town up and down screaming at the
top of my lungs this is a little town oh
yeah I mean this is like close to the
later the Mexican US border in Laredo
Texas and it's very male machismo down
there
and and yeah I was shouting that I was
gay and I didn't give a damn who at who
was that what about this is in your DNA
this is yes yeah I never hid it and
there I was never in the closet closet
of her clothes and tennis shoes yeah
well I decided when I I became
hiv-positive I was I used to be a banker
and I became HIV positive they're gonna
lift the bank to take care of my health
and I almost died and while I was dying
at one point I decided I'm not gonna die
he's looking like a human so I decided
making my transformation because I
something I was wanted to do and I
figured yes yeah yeah I'm gonna do this
my way I decided to this my way and
that's one of the reasons why it doesn't
really bother me when people like people
make fun of me or criticize me or
whatever like whatever yeah yeah they
don't know what I've been through this
life made me what I am
something happened to you also when you
were younger yeah I heard a story you
were raped or something like this yes
yes I was 18 years old and I had just
graduated from high school and left the
little town that I grew up in and
graduated from I had just left I just
graduated that year and I came here to
that fall and yeah that's that's what it
happened yeah but you know that's one of
the many things in life that has made me
who I am and what I am today that's just
one of the things of the many things
that have happened to me in life because
I was raised to be obedient you know and
you you meet someone and you fall in
love and you're you're with him forever
and ever that's the mentality I grew up
with and so life dealt me some really
rude awakenings along the way along life
but what happened when I was 18 years
old I was like fresh from the sticks I
mean I come from a little town it's a
town of 300 people including loaded the
ranches that the outlying ranchers from
the little town so it's very very tiny
town and so I came from that and went to
a city of skyscrapers and I'd stand
there and I look up at the sky scrapers
and I'd get dizzy oh my oh my god what's
going on here yeah and Houston so I
didn't know that you couldn't trust just
anyone and I was in a situation where I
wasn't asking for help I didn't know
what to do and some help presented
itself and but little did I know that it
was there was someone who would do me
wrong and ended up doing me wrong
and but you know I don't even hate the
people that did it it was two guys
because I'm not there I always I want to
be the first person of the stand of the
mountain and say don't do what I've done
did you oh hell no no never never
you know you don't do something like
what I've done to myself to to later on
you know big reddit you know you have to
know right from the very front am i or
am I not gonna regret this ten years
from now and when I started I said I'm
not going to be ready I'm gonna be happy
people who live whom I've lived with and
like my neighbors where I live but now
everybody just loves me they're like
they these like everybody's like taking
me under their wing your energy
pleasant and nice to be around that it's
like get past the visual if you don't
like it interview but it's just too
weird for you get over it because who
you are is about as pleasant and nice
and kind as anyone thank you
well you know and I want to explain
something about my transformation that
directly correlates to what you just
said and that is when I started this
wait you don't have any [ __ ] ears I
can't hear you it's my excuse to some
people I can't hear what you're saying
I'm sorry I have no ears and it's a good
way for some people who are nasty and
negative I just told I can't hear you my
transformation is by and large what
saved my life
after five failed suicide attempts when
I really was serious about my
transformation all of that went away
hadn't happened anymore and it ain't
gonna happen so it's not real happy for
the first time I know for the first time
in my life I can honestly say I'm happy
with my life